McDonald's CEO has resigned after almost 25 years at the fast-food chain...
...and will be replaced by its chief brand officer.
According to a press release from the company,...
...Don Thompson will step down from his position...
...at the top of the iconic restaurant business effective March 1st.
He will be replaced by Steve Easterbrook, who will also serve as president of McDonald's...
...and sit on the company's board of directors.
McDonald's stock was trading about 2% higher in after-hours trading.
Thompson had been under pressure to rehab the restaurant's business,...
...which struggled recently.
In 2014, the company posted its first decline in global same-store sales since 2002.